Toronto Canada we're coming up North
this week gang and we added a third show
there at the Royal Theater still a
couple of ticks left grab the squad come
out and see us yeah gang also uh at rug
garbage.com we have a 20% off all of our
merchandise you go over there toies
slashing prices no promo code need you
just go over there boom it gets whacked
off right when you go to the checkout
get all your official ay merch and then
also over there on patreon we're doing a
contest or if you sign up and if you're
an active patreon user in October of
2023 you get your chance to be on our
garbage interviewed by the big man and
myself do it sign up it's a party
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage M it's
that little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy but they're just a
big old piece of trash trash trash I'm
your host stage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toties in the new edition she is
upstairs beside herself Furious okay at
you whoa that's all I got all right my
co coming at you from right next to me
the dog go back to the writers room on
that one Jesus Christ goddamn strikes
killing me strikes over dude get the get
the staff writers on
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me this young man went from the
produce department to the CEO about 20
years it took him I was a bagger give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you R VI
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
true to [__] cooking baby then
obviously the greatest website of all
time head over there to
www.patreon.com you garbage gang it's a
freaking party over there mhm having a
nice quick shout out to our good pal the
pride of the Chicago comedy scene by way
in North Carolina give it up for T-Bone
McMuffin Toby McMullen everybody what up
boys what up pal man we got the good
homie in the addition yeah we do I
watched this guy rip about 10,000
heaters while we lost all of our money
at blackjacket Vegas likes a heater oh
yeah oh my God I love him especially
when we had that [__] Pit Boss next
to us the whole time oh that guyy stun
with the ply deer the Mexican dude with
the ply deer
he's like I'm pretty thirsty too I don't
know where the beers are kick rocks dude
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time as the long hair said he's a
good pal of ours very funny standup
comedian and of course he is the
producer of the wildly successful Matt
and Shane secret podcast the big
question everybody's mind today is he
garbage this is going to be a slam dunk
ladies and gentlemen give it up for Sean
Gardini hello gentlemen thank you for
having me hey it's a pleasure to be here
give us the scoop man where you from
tell us all about it from Jersey Central
Jersey yeah thanks for tuning in
everybody I know appreciate it I know
where in Jersey uh by Ruckers middlex
County oh man man the [__] armpit the
Garden State baby central New Jersey dud
ain't nothing good happening in Central
newers right in the middle what' your
mom and dad do give us the whole scoop
uh daddy was a policeman really I didn't
know that where in in Central Jersey New
Jersey no kidding did you bring the car
home at night parking in the driveway no
no but he spent a lot of time I don't
want to mess up his pension or nothing
yeah no come
on we're already in the
Frog [__] ratting them out all the
dumps were taken at the house sure okay
park the car in the driveway a home
gamer what are you going to do boss
makes a dollar he makes a dime that's
sure your dad was a cop what' your mom
do Mom kind of bounced around she worked
at Liz Clayborn for a while it's like a
Springsteen
song yeah she work she's like a she
works the
books I'm gar garbage I'm not going toy
wait like for like the like the
corporation LZ Clayborne or like at the
store at the corporation like money [__]
or balance the books or something and
she worked for a carpet company shout
out Buzzy's
carpet what's it carpet sounds you give
haircuts to carpet is your carpet Shaggy
it sounds like they're they're marketing
is like our shit's extra
static okay stinging yeah don't wear a
pair of new socks around here hardwood
lvt so your mom had a pretty good job
did she go to school she go to college
uh yeah she went to college where'd she
go uh [__] Brown College not the
university the college I think man I
think she got the associates Harvard
technical school yeah yeah she got the
associates and nice my mom is her
associates they both I don't think they
got Bachelors but they both went went
for a little stretch okay I was I think
I was the first one to graduate and get
the batch where did you go I went to
Temple oh shout out to T go gentlemen
brothers and sisters it's in our blood
we
can I bleed cherry and white brothers
and
sisters uh yeah one [__] how old is she
she younger than me how young three
years she three years so you guys went
to high school together and all that
[__] yeah I was a senior she was a fresh
public school private school public
school public system Central Jersey
asking you never know okay and uh what
was do you do you still live in that do
your parents still live in the house you
gr up they do okay is it a street I did
for a long time up until a couple of
weeks ago is it a street an Avenue
Avenue an Avenue huh in a Suburban
setting yeah that's pretty bad yeah yeah
you know culdesac no no no is there
there's one around
but we're not allowed on that side of
town is there uh is is there painted
lines on your street like in the middle
no okay so it's it's not a two lane road
is there a to Booth any there's a lot of
cars parked on so okay um what was the
house like uh nice house you know my dad
built it with like his buddies he did
yeah like contractors and you just like
bring the buddies and they build it when
I was like an infant so I've been there
forever where were you guys living while
the house was getting built did you have
another house Brunswick they had a
townhouse okay he built the house yeah
it was like buddies not like own two
hands no way no way they were pulling
permits no way they're called [__]
they called the unions the let them know
they were operating lot of Staples in
that
house how many bedrooms uh three three
bedroom four four one's the office for
my mommy there you go she works there
yeah uh two floors or two floors floors
nice house pool no no pool no pool
what's the driveway situation driveway
driveway and garage paved paved yeah did
they park the car in the garage one can
fit in the garage the other one's the uh
the lounge area for me and my dad smoke
sakes wait the other the other PARTA so
is a two car garage two doors two car
garage one car fits you park one car in
there and then what are you guys sitting
on when you're having your garage
heaters and was this set up like you
were high school kids like is there a
couch in there and [__] yeah my dad has
a sign in there that says I I live in
the garage I sleep in the house oh man
that's the Chill Spot for me and is your
dad retired now is he still working as a
c retired okay is he working or is he
just chilling he's working all right I
don't think he'll ever stop working I
wish what's he doing now he's security
all right there you go that's a fun
that's a good retired top job where's he
security at he works at a school no
kidding and like a concert venue in the
summertime there you go MH he went to
the Snoop Dog concert this weekend this
uh summer Snoop it's me guard dog
yeah we are
related the dog family I didn't even I
didn't even make that connection do you
your long lost cousin Snoop Dog do you
and your dad smoke the same kind of sigs
yeah let's get back to the the the the
Chill Zone as you when did you start
smoking with him uh so that's the thing
my dad quit sigs when I was born uhhuh
as if it would like you know he didn't
want me to smoke sigs which that worked
out good job ID I just saw you I just
saw you steamrolling an American Spirit
okay uh but now we switch the cigars and
he really chops those down really so you
guys sit out there you have a heater he
has a stogy and what are you guys
sitting on what's the Vibes we've
switched a few it used to be just the
like real furniture that they got from
friends and he put them out there but
then we kind of like like a couch or
like a recliner start
B that's [__] Wayne's World out there
it's do sort of like uh sort of like
those little lounge chairs then we kind
of we sweat through those in the
summertime [__] and they got stained
from our gross [__] swe how many sigs are
you smoking out there we chill out there
especially when I was living there we we
chill hard that's the spot when did you
start smoking I was like s 16 17 did you
did they know you smoked at 161 17 no I
HIIT it for a while what's a while
probably 2 well my dad always knew but
he'd be like hide it from your mother so
I'd hide it from my mother sure and uh
it got to a point where I just gave up
but my grandmother she still can't know
I don't she still don't know I have a
very similar family she don't know don't
her I keeps you young you know what I
mean when you got to hide her from your
grandmother and what does your sister do
uh she's she's good she works in
accounting okay she's smarter than me
yeah did she finish
school she did yeah she didn't set the
bar so high she's a Scarlet Knight she
went to Ruckers okay all right there you
go all right not too bad how were your
grades growing up good good I was good
in school yeah yeah what'd you get in
the SATs ah [__] I don't
remember okay I knew you guys were going
to ask that actually remember A and B's
yeah did you get any money to go to
Temple academic scholarship no not
really and where did you stay when you
lived what did you live there did you
commun yeah I was on 16th in Oxford for
like six years six years what are you
doing stay there I worked at uh
President Steve after for a little while
no [__] and you lived on campus two
years after graduation just drove back
and forth hooking everybody up with
tickets who wants to see the sticks
I intern there there you go what was the
grocery store that you guys went to
Growing Up shop right all right shop
right Central Jersey it's got to be
right shop right Stop and Shop sometimes
but the Stop and Shop is dangerous cuz
there's a lot of old folk homes old
folks homes in my uh neighborhood uhuh
so like three times a year they'll drive
one through the [__] they just they
[__] send it to the produce you got
to keep your head on the swivel when
you're in the Stop Shop parking lot
[__] 86 gutas yeah coming through the
baker
that's all right man I was like where
the [__] is he making this connection
they did it's dangerous though okay any
sports growing up yeah I wrestled for
like a long time there you go when did
you start doing that I was probably like
10 nice maybe even younger so you did
that whole circuit the youth wrestling
that's a wild situation in the in the
Northeast yeah yeah that's really
something out you wrestled in high
school yeah seal finals look at you lost
South Playfield beat
right what weight did you wrestle I was
106 for 2 years and then 120 for 2 years
were you cutting weight and all that
[__] a little bit but nothing crazy was
your dad pumped about keep slim well I
didn't smoke so I smoked since I was
like really young you know we'd like
walk the train tracks and smoke whatever
we can get our [__] hands on yeah
been there uh but then I started smoking
heavy once I was done with sports when
did you start smoking weed do you smoke
weed I'm just just for the for the
drawers have you heard me talking for
the past 10 minutes
I am we my synapses are indul since I
was 15 years old you do have the Cadence
of someone who just got robbed for their
lunch
month whatever
man so 15 you started smoke when did you
start drinking probably around the same
time maybe a little ear earlier 14 it's
all adds up how old are you by the way I
don't even know 26 you're 26 all right
young guy um what were the family
vacations like growing up where would
you go hit the shore we hit a couple
good ones but yeah the shore was big
house down the shore no but like we had
friends that had houses they let us
shout out Buzzy he had a house down
there holy of course he's got all that
goddamn carpet money I know I worked for
Buzzy too all work for Buzzy did Buzzy
do well Buzzy does well still he's still
in biz no kid he better [__] give me
a little back end on whatever he gets
all promo C guard dog hook me up with
some wall to wall Buzzy let's go wa so
you guys would stay at his house uh
would he be there with his family yeah
it's like multi level so they live there
fulltime and we'd get like the
downstairs what Shore were you at he was
at Point Pleasant we're like belmare
we're like 30 minutes from belmare and
all that so you stayed up there you
didn't go down to South Jersey no but
Senior Week was in Wildwood I spent a
week down there shout out to the hood
baby okay h of of boards the big what
with the big vacations Disney World uh
Disney World yeah but we went out of the
country like a couple times we hit
Cancun once oh God electric as a kid
yeah what the [__] Cancun we went to the
Bahamas their kids to Cancun we went to
Cancun in the Bahamas in Puerto
Rico at Puerto Rico was with a friend of
mine but I think your dad was
muing what do you mean a friend of yours
you went with his family yeah they
brought us they brought Jesus Christ
Whole Town's [__] dirt bag poor
taking kids to Puerto Rico maybe the
Dominican Republic I'm fried were they
all uh like did you go to all inclusives
yeah yeah they did are you kid the
Bahamas was the biggest one the Bahamas
was crazy I remember going there it was
like it was called Atlantis I thought it
was the real one Atlantis yeah there
people go on their honeymoon man I know
was my Grandma's birthday so she took us
all down [__] so what other extended
family is in uh is in the area you got
your grandom an Grandma's down there
ants in Canada now that's a whole
another story shout out an Cath she
draft
dodging that's crazy the whole another
podcast uh she's up there in Alberta
yeah my you know everyone kind of stays
where they all live there forever
cousins and all that stuff around cuz
he's over there yeah and 100% Italian no
half Irish half Italian your mom's Irish
your dad's Italian no both are half and
half it's the true it's the true mix
Jesus Christ what was the cooking
situation growing up any good Italian
food in the house m love you yeah but it
cooking was no good who wants potatoes
and marinara you
know Mom I remember I used to [__] all
the time she'd make there chicken a lot
a lot lots of chicken shake and bake I
don't even know what she was doing back
in the day she was trying to innovate
but you know it was
good would you do Sunday dinner and
stuff like that as a family not really
grandma would whip up some good Sunday
dinner yeah okay good Italian okay uh
she's part of the Italian American Club
shout out to that there you go little
Sunday Sunday sauce and Dad yeah Dad
does good lasagna he does it every
Christmas he makes the like the slick
back hair he's got he's bald dude my dad
looks like Michael chicklas oh no [__]
Commish shout out to him I'm picturing
him in full police uniform with an apron
yeah put a cigar in his mouth hey watch
your meatballs I got to go Ser this
Warren all
right I got a b& two houses is down um
where would you do Christmas would it be
at your house or over at your Grandmom's
uh we'd switch uh we do Christmas Eve at
Grandma's Christmas Day at our house all
right that's nice would Grandma come
over to the house with you guys yeah she
would would she stay over to get out
though no you got to drive you got you
got to shower her around you got to pick
her up and where's your grandpa did he
pass yeah he's no longer with us God
Rest his soul how
long uh my uh my her husband died when I
was really young in like grade school
okay okay uh yeah wait you just refer to
your grandfather's your grandma's
husband or was that a yeah because my
other my dad's dad's dead too okay he
died more recently okay yeah yeah and
what did you call them what you what
were your names for your grandp Grandpa
Grandma Grandpa Grandma all right great
great great grandma was Nona there you
go that's Italian right yeah all right
could she cook she was old dude front of
shop
right who would babysit you as a kid do
you remember uh we had a lot of hotties
neighborhood hotties that would come I
remember this one lady with a purple car
would come and oh my God I was in love
with her how old was she she's probably
like 15 at the time but she looked about
30 to me she's old lot of
woman you're at the top of the steps
just packing a pack of smokes good to
see it car's running good huh you want
to hit the Chill Spot later I got a
table for two with our name on it the
neighborhood hotties that's all right
yeah we had neighborhood hotties and my
aunt my aunt Cathy is the best I love
her she would come she would babysit you
yeah bring us candy and [__] what was
the uh did you would your parents let
you eat whatever you wanted when you
were a kid or was it tight uh it was
pretty I had a I'm still on a bad diet
pretty loose sugar cereal in the house
yeah yeah whatever what would be a
typical breakfast before like Middle
School oh [__] Eggos cereal toaster
strudel maybe toaster strudel family
that's nice a little money in the house
yeah some eggs maybe mommy daddy make
you some scrambies she'd hook them up
you like chees in your scrambies now I
do at the time I was just salt and
pepper what the [__] what little kid did
you just salt and pepper I know
yeah he's wild man I feel like you were
born with a cup of black coffee
complaining about the boss being on your
ass yeah
literally holy [__] um what was the pet
situation uh we had Annie she's a nice
little mut okay she passed
away now we got Ralphie he's a pity he's
a Pity mix she's the [__] best uh and
then we my Grandma had Dallas we'd watch
her a lot she was a big Doberman okay
Doberman they all have like nine
different personalities every every
character he's talking about I'm all
over the place I haven't thought about
this [__] in a while uh any snakes any
birds any lizards any Turtles anything
like that a few dead hamsters okay you
know that didn't didn't last long
you were hamster people D I brought up
Dallas because we were watching we'd
watch Dallas a lot for my grandma MH and
one day me and my sister came downstairs
to watch the cartoons we were eating
cereal and Dallas was sleeping on the
bed we hung out with her for like 2
hours oh God and uh my parents came down
and turns out we were just hanging out
with a dead dog the entire time now when
you say on the bed whose bed was it like
her bed her little pillow type thing so
you watch Saturday morning cartoons with
a dead dog yeah for about a couple hours
and then my mom came down started crying
wait they hadn't noticed it yet legs
they sleep in the air what the [__] RI
Morse had set in it's a cold ass dog
over there they're sleeping we woke up
early they didn't come down for a little
while and then when they came down they
were like this dog's dead dog is clearly
dead you didn't know it was dead no we
were kids you know holy [__] man that's
[__] why uh ke talk about Helix shout
out to Helix I fart in one earlier today
shout out to Helix mattress everybody
just when you thought Helix couldn't get
any better that coming at you with the
elites throwing smoke talking about the
elite collection gang do yourself a
favor get over there Helix take the quiz
they got six different mattress models
in the elite collection that you are
going to love yeah they're tell it
specifically for your sleep positions
and firmness like the big man said you
go over there you take the quiz and you
might be sitting there thinking what's
the quiz I don't know two three minutes
two three minutes who ain't got two
three minutes for better sleep I know I
did cuz I took the test and it gave me a
Twilight model I led it so much I got a
king took me to spank it this
morning in a helix obviously I'm a
company man gentlemen uh Helix knows uh
that there's no better way to test a
mattress than actually use it in your
home that's why they offer a 100 night
free trial and a 10 to 15E warranty to
test things out they got you covered
baby check they check your six while
you're snoozing Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
garbage and use the code Helix partner2
baby that's helixsleep.com garbage code
Helix partner2 to get their best offer
yet it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now if you snooze you lose
but you probably can't snooze cuz you're
in a shitty bed go to helixsleep.com do
it K let's talk about butcher box shout
out to butcher box the OG's in the game
big fan of the butcher box over here at
Ru garbage I got a fridge full of meat
that I don't know what to do with I just
did the ribs not that long ago they were
absolutely delicious threw them in the
oven came out oh so tender I still got
ham burger meat that I'm baby do I make
a nice Samy with that man they do a good
job over there put your box gang do
yourself a favor cuz when you go to the
grocery store you're getting what you
get you get what's on the shelf and I'll
tell you what most of the time it ain't
grass-fed it ain't grass finish it ain't
wild CAU it ain't free range but it puts
your box you're getting all of the above
baby yeah with exclusive member deals
and the ability to totally customize
your box or they can just they can run
it and gun it with let them do it they
know what they're doing but if you're a
little picky and you like to hear
control freak like like me you like to
have a little say um they have recipe
guys to help you with uh to whip up
incredible meals butcher box is ready to
help you level up the kitchen and that's
what they do and put your boxes giving
our you garbage listeners a special deal
because we're in bed with these we love
the butcher box sign up today using Code
ay to receive ground beef for Life plus
a $20 off your first order that's 2 lbs
at Ground be free in every box for the
lifetime of your membership plus 20
bucks off your first order when you sign
up at butcherbox.com use the code a
that's butcherbox.com
code a and get hamburger meat coming out
your ears yeah what was the first
job oh buzzies buzzies yeah probably I I
was Ripp I was ripping up like flooring
for okay ever so he was an install guy
yeah install yeah did he have a showroom
or does he have a show no it's all just
like there's no buzzies there's no place
that's buzzes no corporate headquarters
no technically I guess it's my mom's
office in our house all right that's the
showroom yeah but no no showroom I would
just go in and I never really learned
how to install until you know a couple
years ago I was still doing it okay so
they sort of taught me the ropes but I
was mainly just there to rip up [__] and
that was the garbage boy not bad would
you uh pack your lunch or school or buy
uh once I got older I'd buy and what'
that look like how was the school lunch
over there it's pretty good pizza pizza
was good I remember that Buffalo chicky
Pizza really Dam high school that's
pretty fancy what year did you graduate
high school uh
2015 damn that's I mean that's the
height of buffalo chicken pizza was the
was the area was there money in the area
or was it a middle class area yeah
there's money but my area sure sort of
in the middle and you drive to another
neighborhood it's like huge houses you
know so so you had that mix in school
yeah all right that's good that's all
right big mix yeah what was the uh when
was the first time you had Nutella you
remember I still haven't tried it to be
honest that commie [__] out of my face
nah probably I don't know probably in
high school probably but I was never big
Nutella guy what was the peanut butter
and jelly situation PB and J was nice
you're all about it creamy no chunks
creamy Welches in the squirty bottle oh
you ever have a fluffer Nutter n no I I
have but not your go to like to keep it
simple what was the ice cream in the
house growing up what were
um briers Bri yeah uh half chocolate
half vanilla okay take all the chocolate
leave the whole half of the vanilla
there of course all adding up uh what
about the chocolate syrup were your
Hershey's family Hershey's yeah
gentlemen the milk do you remember was
it whole was it skim was it 2% 2% I
think they'd go on a health kick go to
skim for a little while [__] hatte
that would happened once every like nine
months and it [__] sucked were you
allowed to eat in your room as a kid
yeah yeah rules weren't so strict yeah
it doesn't Pretty like no what were the
posters up in the room do you remember
they're still there it's all the same I
remember is your room as it was yeah it
in high school at least you got to think
it's not that long you know it's not
crazy long ago he's the first guest from
that a fly landed on
him decomposing as we speak Jesus Christ
got to Sten your death he's like Dallas
over here we've been podcasting for two
hours with a dead guard dog I've been
dead the whole time [__] a sick sent
flies in his mouth In the Arms of an
Angel every there choking on a bee oh
for the price of one cup of coffee today
man [__] you can support a dying
podcaster oh God okay what was the first
concert I also hold on pinning that back
to the posters what's on there yeah
posters right now I got some cool ones
going I got the well I will be the judge
of that but okay
I got the Uncle Sam we want you up in
the room right now that's pry that's a
CL I was not expecting that Keys poster
up there I got a Red Hot Chili Peppers
poster up there which I know Toby hates
we were just getting into that last
night I respect shout out to rhcp 2015
the Chili Peppers all right I like that
that was big pepperhead I thought you
going to say like Britney Spears and all
that [__] no no I was a Rocka and then I
got a I have something that my grandpa
Drew up on the wall all right it's like
a he used to love you know those felt
coloring things that sort of went away
where it'd be like a blank sheet felt ah
it's oh it's my background on my like J
like a black light poster type thing
like this oh yeah so he used the magic
marker and color it all in that's pretty
good yeah he was talented artist okay I
know you're my dad's dad I know you're a
fisherman does that come from the family
yeah that was my dad's he used to like
to fish a lot so they'd take us around
we go to the cabin up on like the
Delaware Water Gap did you guys have a
cabin up there no they were it was like
a split thing
buzzies there Hercules Rod and Gun Club
shout out to Hercules rotting gun club
shout out to a good rotting gun club the
ginis were members there so you'd get
your weekend and you'd go up there and
invite all your family and You' swim and
get drunk and all right that's a little
vacation you do that in the summer we do
that yeah every summer bad uh what was
the soap in the house growing up you
remember what' you use bar no never bar
the pumps really whatever pumps my mom
could get at TJ Maxx and would you
barehanded or do you have a washcloth or
a loofah for the shower you use the
washcloth washcloth family would you
share that washcloth or would absolutely
not uh maybe if I yeah if someone else
used a shower they'd probably use my
washcloth but the kids had a shower and
me and my sis both had our own
respective washcloths okay no lofers
though so your parents say you had two
uh two bath yeah two B two bathrooms and
then they had an addition now we got
three nice pop put on an addition when
that go up then Middle School maybe I
was probably lot of overtime that year I
bet there he goes any ping pong pool
tables bumper pool yeah you know what we
had in the basement was uh one of those
tables where you could flip it who and
it and it uh that was a Christmas
present one year that was sick the pool
table the pool table it's never works
it's always un full SI no little bit
small it's got to get down the stairs
all the balls roll to the one side cuz
it's not level at all and then there's
like ping pong on the other side and
wait it would flip yeah and is that
basement finished or partly finished
partly partly finished but then there's
a section that's you know doored off
that's that's the dojo that's where we
got the heavy bag and the liftting in
the bench press in there can't hit a
heavy bag in carpet there's definitely a
dehumidifier in there too there's a high
system down there you ever P you have a
sump pump down there oh yeah you peeing
that thing how'd you
know that was me and my dad's
secret and it floods too you think
you're the only dirt bag to ever pain a
some PP I was going to ask you the
basement flood a lot uh yeah especially
during Sandy yeah during Sandy I guess I
guess we got four bathrooms if you got
some three and a half you can't shower
in that uh you ever burn a Jersey no
have not okay what do you call a remote
remote okay clicker it used to be the
clicker and then they transition to the
remote clicker is bad clicker was all
right get the clicker yeah yeah is it a
drugstore or a pharmacy Pharmacy okay
where would you go CVS CVS Walgreens
used to be a Right Aid Walgreens bought
it out okay I was a Right Aid Man myself
what was the uh the doctor situation
growing up would you go to a like a
professional Center or was it a doctor's
office in a house it was a professional
Center but there's like you know the
dentist offices above it and stuff sure
short and I went to that pediatrician
until about 3 years ago yeah I went
after college I was the last time I went
to him you're comfortable with him I did
that as long as I could trusted him mine
was
new I went for the first time like 21
you're getting an SD SD test on a car on
a car
bed uh do you know who Chum Lee is of
course rest God Rest his soul too rest
in peace big
guy your family ever take any pictures
in matching outfits no like all in white
on the beach or anything like that no
who's your dad's team is he an eagles
man he's a Giants guy is he really
interesting when's the last time you ate
a
vegetable smoked out of an apple on the
way uh it's been a
while if you count the the celery with
those wings last night that that was a
veggie is that the lifestyle these days
you got your own place lifestyle is bad
I've been trying to eat better recently
cuz I've been experiencing gut health
issues but sure I didn't really stick to
it you cook at the house at your
apartment I started recently what are
you throwing down if I don't ask steak
and potatoes okay eggs and bakey okay
it's pretty much it you go to the
grocery store yourself yeah well as of
recently yeah what are you hitting over
there Trade Fair we got key Foods key
Foods key Foods if I want to walk and
then we got the
one I don't want to divulge my location
but we I forget what it's called now I
think I know what you're talking about a
little bit nicer was there a beware of
dog sign at your house growing up no no
he got bedroom now there was a beware uh
Sean's room do not enter on my door oh
that's awesome I had it it's my mess and
I love it hanging on my front
door uh some Nickel in the house I
assume your dad being a a law officer oh
yeah Daddy's got a gun Daddy's got a
couple of guns all right I used to take
pictures with him and post them on like
Facebook like posting with my daddy's
gun I us kicked out of school Jesus
Christ uh have you ever owned or worn
cargo
sweatpants no but I got a lot of cargo
regular pant really yeah those are my
favorites any trouble in school as a kid
you get suspended you get detention yeah
I got suspended once what would you do I
uh I stabbed my friend
okay it was a misunderstanding of course
I not on his
part we were horsing around and um and I
was like [__] with him and then I
broke skin with like a dull thing like
file thing from shop class okay and he
ratted on me and I [__] Jes I almost got
arrested you almost got arrested yeah
what the [__] pull a couple of strings
no thankfully he didn't press chares so
I was good but they were threatening
that I was going to go to the boys home
and I was really scared about that dude
I used to hate that [__] my Mom would
hit me with that every once in a while
the cops were saying they were going to
yeah what the f did you say we were
goofing around it was an accident yeah I
did a crime of passionist I think Daddy
did get me out of that one but send you
to the boy home M have you ever gotten
out of a ticket yeah I got the gold card
on me right now there you go mhm I like
to hear it any instruments growing up
you play anything I played the saxophone
in grade school did you yeah Alto tener
oo big boy I I don't remember [__] I
don't I used to know how to read music I
don't remember it anymore I used to I
used to be like baffled by how they
would just give those to kids I think
you had to rent them didn't you you had
to put money I rented them from the
school you got a brand new saxophone I
was like I'm never going to [__]
touch this thing went back like two
weeks later I wonder you guys are
hemorrhaging
money any
any Reaganomics what are you talking
about [__] wasw no you
guys uh goddamn Schoolboard don't know
what the [__] they're doing H okay you
know how to use chopsticks no Shane
tried to teach me the other day he was
getting mad at me cuz I couldn't figure
it out takes a while yeah [__] that [__]
da do you dabble all over Cuisine wise
or do you stick to mea and potatoes I'm
pretty Mee and potatoes I got a toddler
diet really I'm pretty picky I'm I'm
branching out I will Branch out but how
you cooking that steak on a pan No
temperature-
wise they cut it until it looks good
yeah what do you if you go to a
restaurant how would you order your
steak I get it medium but someone told
me I should get it um
R cuz that's the way rich people eat
their steaks or whatever true you're
eating it with chopsticks yeah they took
us some fancy steakhous recently I tried
to order medium and I got scolded for it
I just thought that's what you did
that's all right medium rare is better
though what's uh what's like a nice
restaurant you and your lady will go out
to like it's say it's the anniversary a
birthday where you going went to Barkley
Prime last
one nice down down Square she holy [__]
no I paid but I feel like you were
wearing the exact same thing you're
wearing I was dressed like [__] dude we
do okay oh topic of wardrobe what's the
nicest thing you do in a suit I have a
suit yeah okay when was the last time
you wore it when my Grandpa died
probably I knew that was coming Jesus
that's true Doom and Gloom with this I
don't mean we went to a wedding it was a
wedding when the dog died you were to
Dallas's
funeral where'd you get that suit oh
Jesus I don't know Men's Warehouse or
something probably okay I respect it
I've had it for God knows how since I
graduated college I've had it that was
the first suit I got can you tie a tie
no okay I did I forgot it same same
thing with the saxophone lay off the
dope will you get Jes I
know forgetting everything um who was
your mom's favorite singer growing up do
she have a favorite group or oh I don't
know I I remember the rent soundtrack
was on a lot in the car really yeah they
love the rent soundtrack they love the
Broadway they love Phantom of the Opera
your dad too I think he just kind of
appeases her and listens to it but can't
get a read on these people I no that's
what I said they all have different
personal I thought for sure you going to
say Bon Joi oh well yeah of course they
just saw they just saw Springsteen like
two weeks ago did they
yeah the tickets are expensive too uh
have you ever made your own jello shots
no h when was the last time you smoked a
Black and Mild
H probably like a couple weeks
ago okay do you floss every day I've
been trying to get back into the
flossing cuz my teeth hurt lately but
uh what kind of toothpaste are you using
you're like Charlie when it's always
Sunday it's always Philly Any Given
Sunday get get sedine if your teeth hurt
sedine that's what they say my lady's
trying to get me on the yeah I'm telling
you it'll work overnight that that'll go
away it does feel better when I use it
100% you use mouthwash no what's the
Q-tip situation you Q-tip after the
shower I try to I do they say it's bad
for you I do anyway and uh I do the uh
the paper towel in the ear too try to
get the outsides okay my ears get [__]
I'm wearing headphones all day so my
ears are nasty it's like a backat cave
in there any moisturizer you any routine
no nothing no you wash your hair that
bab see the Sandpaper face this is what
God gave me 26 dude you look 38 26 years
young baby let's
go uh any milk crates in the apartment
at the moment no but at home there
there's there's some milk crates yeah I
keep all my [__] in the milk crate in
the in your bedroom yeah all right
that's all right you steal those I don't
know how the [__] we got them yeah
nobody no one knows how you get them you
just acquire them yeah they're just
there after a while do you make your bed
every morning no I I don't make it at
all and what do you have you have a king
you have a Queen full a full I got a
tiny room right now whoa it's 10 by 10
what else is in that room just a bed bed
dresser desk TV TV play video games in
there yeah yeah do everything in there
in my apartment's there do you live by
yourself or do you have roommates no
shout out Shane o Conor I live with
Shane o Conor Philly bro nice okay all
right huh who's cutting the hair nobody
apparently yeah nobody right now but uh
got Floy Oxana and queens was hooking me
up for a while but who's that some lady
and queens but she works at a barber
shop you just said you sound like you
ran into her on the street she works at
the Key Food you get a nice haircut out
there in Queens there's a lot of little
spots out there you get a nice trim they
know what they're doing out there they
all look like Bond villains too guys
missing half a head or whatever you know
do you read it all I I've been trying to
but what are you reading now I have this
uh fishing book by Thomas MCU okay that
big Chrissy gave it to me shout out big
Chrissy non-fiction uh yeah it's just
about it's pretty boring honestly I
might have to S sounds riveting yeah how
good of a fisherman are you can you fly
fish no can you tie a you're like a like
what do you you're like a fresh water
you're a fresh water fresh water I fish
bass and catfish sometimes most and you
do pretty well from from what I've seen
you catch a fish yeah kind of Rod you
banging with I got this ugly stick a
little cheap thing bit casting rod H
fast action can you clean a fish no I've
never eaten anything I've C them before
I throw it all back my grandpa used to
cut it all up for us do you eat fish
yeah yeah oysters I just recently had
oysters a raw oyster yeah shrimp lobster
crab you do all that stuff all that
stuff I love all that stuff all right
you're not that picky that's pretty good
you bite your fingernails or do you clip
them bite them yeah yeah bite them and
file them down what do what do you do
with them when you bite them where do
they go spit them wherever they land
well you do that in the apartment yeah
put the couch or whatever mhm
yeah man
can you do the blood gang sign with your
fingers uh no okay can you whistle yeah
with your fingers no not with my fingers
but okay do something like that all
right it's not bad if you're in the
apartment you drop something on the
floor you still going to eat it real
quick uh depends what it is if it's a
carpet will you do it on the
carpet uh yeah really it depends what it
is if it's something dry that's yeah
something dry I will pretzel nugget you
got to pick up piece of steak drops on
the floor you throwing that down a
hatch depends what's on the floor if
there if I threw my fingers in the
fingernails there earlier that day it's
protein yeah h Huh anybody in your
family uh use the napkin over the shirt
when they eat no no where would be where
would where would your dad and mom take
you to dinner like as a treat as kids
where would you go did good on the
report card or something it was it was
chilies every birthday for about 15
years chilies ain't nothing wrong with
it I want my baby back baby back baby my
dad used to sing me that to help me go
to sleep when I was little holy [__]
that's [__] we're a chain restaurant
family what is your favorite chain
restaurant it's got to be chilly just
cuz it hold a special place in my heart
your go to order to Chili's triple
Dipper double up on the Boneless bites
and then freestyle whatever the third
one
is I mean he ordered that he rattled
that off poet yeah how could you not
love this guy shout out to guard dog
dude man I have an incriminating piece
of information I'd like to share with
you guys just for the hell of it I don't
think I've ever said it on a podcast
before but my my dad's parents uh
they're no longer with us but when they
were with us they were named Robert and
Roberta that was my grandma and
grandpa's name O Bobby and Bobby Jean
that were that's what they were called
Bobby je they met in a rodeo they used
to ride horses together oh [__] [__]
John Cougar melon I know and I think my
other grandpa used to fix cars for the
mob but that's what every Italian every
Italian's like two steps away Bobby
Jean's a great name man [__] love
Bobby Jean and they were Jersey yeah
everyone's Jersey middlex County South
River shout out to the River Rats any
hairdressers or strippers in the family
at all no no uh no no no no estheticians
that's what we call them okay anybody in
your family have any men have just a
calf tattoo uh definitely but not that I
can recall does the old man have fats I
imagine your pop's got a tat no but pops
is getting big on tats now is he getting
them no he's he's always sending me like
Celtic crosses and stuff that and I'm
like dude we haven't been to church in
like a decade I could see that yeah he
wants a Celtic cross on he wants to get
something yeah anybody any men in your
family with uh their ear
pierced sorry um not that I can recall
now did you ever have your ear pierced
no never no they'd ripped that out
probably any ponytails male ponytails uh
yes like extended family yes but
immediate no okay where would you go
sledding when you were a kid Thompson
Park shout out Thompson Park Devil's
Hill Old Man's
Bluff uh Devil's Hill when was the last
time you were out of dve
Busters uh maybe like a year or two ago
once the Philly one solid got out of
their live thank God the same
time yeah huh nowadays do you shower at
night or shower in the morning
uh mix of both I shouted before I came
here thank you yeah no don't mention
it you could have fooled me dude look
like you slept in the back of a Corvette
dude what the [__] yeah kind of threw it
out there as a brag too came here that's
how much I like is of respect uh okay
switch it up though yeah you have a
go-to karaoke song um a chunk of coal by
Johnny Cash or uh the cranberry zombie
but I never seen karaoke but if I do
have to bust it out one day I'm doing
either one of those I respect that
that's very eclectic mhm will you dance
at a wedding will you cut a rug depends
how drunk I get but I usually I'm
usually a Wallflower at a wedding do you
usually get pretty drunk at a wedding
yeah usually get pretty drunk
everywhere what uh if you're at a cash
bar at a wedding what are you tipping
what do you have a system of tipping or
do you just not tip he's still young
yeah I haven't had much experience with
being able to most of my weddings were
being the little I when I was young I
used to dance like crazy at weddings
sure still aunts and uncles still bring
it up to me cuz I used to cut a rug
remember Timmy's wedding that that dog
would not sit down have you ever been in
a wedding as a kid the ring bear or
whatever that's like I hit three three
of my cousins had weddings like in a row
nice those are most of the weddings I've
been to start charging I like it yeah
then the one I went to recently I
probably gave him like 4 40 bucks or
something at the end of the night cuz it
was open bar the bartender yeah what'
you give as a gift I think we gave like
200y who's we me and my lady okay that's
all right that's respectable that's good
uh were you ever a Paul Bearer no no
what the hell is that you carry the
casket at a uh maybe I I have no I don't
think so I was always too young I feel
like that's something in to remember I
know maybe I have maybe I did carry a
dead body one time I think I was sort of
like support cuz they want to make me
feel like man I was young I got you I
got you any braces as a kid no perfect
teeth as you could tell okay he quickly
closed his mouth on we both f up perfect
teeth my teeth look like candy corn
they're rotting out of my head you were
just saying they hurt yeah I got to do
something about that uh have you ever
been to a bob strip
club no are you a strip club guy only
time I've ever been to a strip club is
with my dad on my 21st birthday wa just
you and him Atlantic City yeah we tried
to bring little s and big sell that's my
best friend little s his dad is Big sell
be weird if it was the other way
around this is my best friend he's 58
this is his son I don't like the kid but
he brings him everywhere we go little s
and big S left cuz their mother was
yelling at him okay so for going and my
dad called them [__] and then we
stayed for like we took their drink
tickets they got there and left yeah
they're getting hollered at so they left
and me and my dad were like all right
well give us your drink tickets and
we'll d That's I don't I didn't really
like it but it's not your cup of tea no
I I sort of feel bad for the ladies sure
did you get a lap dance no okay we just
threw money at him I don't want to my
dad might listen to this but he was like
a fish in water at that strip club it
was pretty yeah weird to watch you knew
what he was doing yeah t me the road T
me everything he knows it's like a large
mouth going after power that [__] guy
yeah that was fun though that was a nice
memory 21st birthday we went to Atlantic
City do you remember the name of the
establishment no God no okay let me ask
you this say you went to a baseball game
you went to a Phillies game not a
playoff game all right just a regular
game you catch a home run ball there's a
there's a young kid right in front of
you you giving them the ball or you
hanging on to it you got to give the kid
the ball gentlemen you don't want to but
you no I don't want to soda in the house
growing up yeah lots of soda two liters
constantly Coca-Cola Coca-Cola Dr Pepper
for special occasion two lers of Dr
Pepper at the crib yeah we still do we
have stockpile in the garage in the
Chill Spot all two liters yeah that's
how they roll well Dad gets his diet
Coke cans cuz he likes it that way
that's how a gentleman should drink diet
cola but yeah I like the cans more too
but you just save a buck when you get
the two lers yeah put those sideways in
the fridge M now they even have the
little well I thought that was for two
liters I think it's for fancier things
but the little hook that you could hang
it on or whatever Jesus okay how do you
feel about the patty melt you know what
a patty melt is like a grilled cheese
with a burger on it yeah sounds good to
me you guys want to go get
some do you eat liver and onions no [__]
no I could see you really good doubt on
that dud when you asked it I was like
what the [__] are you talking about like
makes a lot of sense yeah dude no I
never I'm too picky for that this a
T-bone too that's what I was laughing at
before you ever walk on a
highway no never walked up the highway
no I don't think so actually on the road
maybe to like go get sigs or something
yeah crossing the highway that's scary
feel like a Frogger you you tried to do
everything in your power not to do that
you're like I don't need them and then
you're like all right maybe I'll [__]
need [__] jump in a median um have
you ever considered yourself good at
laser tag I yeah I am good at laser tag
not considered I'm known just went a
couple months agoan did yeah where'd you
go uh Chelsea Pierce
at the
Bolero a nice course over there do you
have any paintball guns when you were a
kid uh no airsoft guns though were big
that got big yeah was that I used to
have a lot of Airsoft guns it was my
favorite thing to do BB gun yeah BB gun
rifle pelic gun yeah I had them all
Chinese stars no I wish I wanted them so
bad my friend Logan Buzzy son had a
arsenal of blades we just go in there
and look at
them what was the uh what was the spank
bank like when you were a kid were you
on the computer cuz you're cuz you're
iPod Touch really you were jerking off
to an iPod Touch good for you first
generation no no nudie mags under the
bed or anything like that out in the
woods all that huh we' we'd look at them
we'd go to the corner store and like get
them for fun but you don't need that
[__] we had the good stuff at home
[__] Mainline in that stuff it's not
that's why I'm probably fried h keep
baking soda in your
refrigerator yes yeah I don't think it's
doing nothing at the house you do now
you yeah I do well it was there when I
moved in and I just left it in there
it's probably
mayonnaise um have you ever done that
punching bag machine game at a carnival
or anything no I'm too scared of what it
would say me too any old timey photos of
the family on the boardwalk or anything
like that dressed up as gangsters or
Cowboys yeah a couple my my one cousin
used to do one every single year so they
just the whole stairway has just them
throughout the years dressed up as
different sorts of criminals tough look
going up the staircase and I have one
where I have two guns and I'm like a
Todd not a toddler but like a little kid
and my Aunt Kathy and my cousin Jules
are on either side of me dressed like
hookers I know that picture that's the
Christmas C right there that's a nice
one it's still in the house Jesus Christ
what uh what are you keeping your Loose
Change in at the house what's the re
receptacle I got a weird little tin
container thing okay throw pretty much
anything I have old ashtray I put change
in I have a lot of change at the house
used to do the [__] big jug remember
those water jug fill those that like 20
grand out of that thing no it's I think
it's only like 800 bucks but in your
head you're like we're going to T once
we cash this thing my parents just
sleeved all their coins up sleeved they
did it themselves you sleeve them cuz
you lose money at the coin star holy
[__] they sit at the kitchen table and
[__] knock that out what the what was
the hall I don't know I think they got
like 30 bucks sitting there right now
Jesus the [__] I thought you were going
to say a couple of grand no well I think
that was a small small yield do you know
how to play dominoes nah I could really
see out on Steinway riing butts with the
80-year-old dudes be nice what shows did
you watch as a family as a kid did you
have any shows that you sat and watch
together Jeopardy we'd watch a lot we
still do that well when I'm home we
watch Jeopardy I try to get all the
questions right to show my family that
I'm smarter than them how do the ginis
do in Jeopardy uh we're pretty good yeah
if there's a good fellow's category or
not the men are good the women aren't as
good cuz their brains are smaller but
sure that's that's
science that's Jersey science for you
uhuh do you remember where you kept the
butter as a kid was it in the
refrigerator or on the counter in the
fridge and then we got the dish on the
counter with the with the soft one
doubled up up the backups are in the
fridge very classy gentlemen have you
ever gotten a massage a manicure or a
pedicure just recently Shane got me a
massage I would have never got I I
didn't like it it makes me feel kind of
weird okay guy or girl a lady yeah all
right it was it was all right not bad um
was the light always on in the fridge as
a kid or was it it sometimes out was it
ever dark in there the bulb going down
dad's pretty good my dad's pretty good
at replacing that stuff handyman mhm
he's very handy H you sneaking snacks
into a movie theater oh yeah and you do
that as a family oh yeah yeah what were
the snacks candies go to the pharmacy
before get like a big bag of Gummy Bears
or something got your poison Gummy Bears
I do like the gummies yeah I'm more of a
sweet guy Haribo yeah okay but I I go
Savory Every Time popcorn over candy
really sure I agree with that have you
ever met have you ever met anyone who's
claimed to see the Jersey
Devil uh yeah yeah most of North Jersey
lay it on us well I don't it's a tricky
thing cuz like when you're a kid I think
they're just trying to scare you so they
say they've like seen it you know like I
had a neighbor who would try to scare me
a lot he has a chicken Coupe he used to
they would make noise in the morning and
I remember one time he would always
dress up super scary on Halloween and
like try to scare us did he have kids
yeah he had kids too they're our friends
so sheesh you have a bathing suit yeah I
got one you got one yeah I use it board
shorts or we got the
elastic actually I got two one board
short one like Nike with the elastic
they're nice yeah right I wear them at
shorts I wear shorts though sometimes
yeah I didn't think you were going to
the [__] south of France can you ski
at all uh not well but yeah
okay all
right I don't know man real close here
what
close I mean I'm not even trying I
should have started this like uh B
rabbit in the Eighth Mile just told you
all of it immediately he coming off the
Dome I like it uh um what was the frozen
pizza situation growing up djo and elos
nice djo for like nice sure some Mar
something a nice Friday night pie IO is
for you know you're strapped for lunch
or something like that and was there
what was a local pizza spot in the
hometown Enzo was the spot for a while
we could ride our bikes there sounds all
right one time I found 20 bucks we went
straight to Enzo's and just blew it
all Enzo you ain't going to believe this
and there but that switched a lot
there's Pinos Pap Pizza the same spot
switched yeah it switched a lot it's
switched right now ooh that ain't a good
sign but Enzo was the one Enzo was the
man quality differ from place to play
from name to name yeah but you know it's
all sort of the same it's all sort of
the same [__] I don't like that did you
ever did you ever do dip like yeah yeah
I used to do that when I
wrestled uh that's how I kind of started
that's how I got hooked because all the
wrestlers would chew yeah to spit okay
have you ever smoked a Sig with a dip in
no no no I hated dip I would just do it
cuz I thought I had to cuz they were all
older than me so I wanted them to think
I was cool sure that's why I smoke still
yeah press those 50 year
old nah never never Double Di though
what uh you got a car now yeah what kind
of car are you whipping around 2010
Honda cord brand new used what though
not certified but pre-owned yeah me too
I just yeah how many miles are on it uh
80,000 that's not bad yeah what was the
first car growing up that you got a 96
Ford Thunderbird
what really it's not nice though
Thunderbird makes it seem nice no I
think I a 96 Thunderbird yeah Coupe
where did you there's a boat dude my
uncle owns a body shop my grandpa used
to own it okay sh out College
Tire He's got everybody you are a small
Central Jersey small like the goddamn
Yellow Pages shout out to Buzzy shout
out to
anzos but yeah now my uncle runs it so
they get a lot of cars in and out of
there yeah bright red though baby cherry
red wow that thing it looks like it's
got like Bonville a boohemoth doors were
[__] 50 ft long yeah I drove that for
a while damn what was the sound system
in there like did you put like a head
unit in yeah I did yeah I put a little
Pioneer radio pioner put my uh so I
could hook my phone up to it but before
that I had the cassette with the string
with the cord coming out of it I still
as much as I know about technology I
have no idea how that works why does
that work yeah I work in audio and I
don't know how that I know I I own this
production company I have no idea how
that works I want to know who the [__]
figured that out how does that can we
get a rundown on that do you know Toby I
was taking a note I have no idea what
you're talking about the the cassette
with the wire that plugs in and then you
can play like an iPod oh oh yeah yeah
yeah I know how that works magic dude no
one knows how that works dude that's
insane doesn't make any sense makes me
think they're lying to us about a bunch
of [__] there's no way that should
[__] work that's better dude that's
better that's it was way better than
that's better technology than I have now
I was just think thinking about that
yesterday yeah it's way better than the
Bluetooth just [__] popped that in
100% how do you go digital analog like
that man there's people in N that really
know what they're doing anybody in the
family ever claimed to have seen a
UFO uh yeah me really but it was just
that Elon mus thing all right this kid's
an idiot remember that star link he had
going through the sky that tricked me
for a good couple hours till I went on
Twitter and real thing that was all over
the news and Twitter billboard okay
there one of those plages flying with
this thing on the back I mean I'm you
know I'm I have all the evidence I need
to render a conclusion I feel I me yeah
the kid's trash but we're having a good
time here this is fun uh do you
currently have any Kohl's Cash no but
Mom's roll she's doing the books with it
mhm what kind of plastic are you
throwing around these days what kind of
credit cards I got a [__] metal boy
now you DX mhm there you go kids doing
all right flights and stuff get the
points and [__] but other than that I
got the Discover you have a Discover
Card I've had that since I was 17 how's
a divorce going hey dude that's a joke
you make every time and I love it but it
plays extra well 26-year-old kid with 17
he got it 17 parents hooked me up with
it so I could get my credit score going
or something like that dude a Discover
Card crazy I put my Spotify on it that's
all I had on it for like five years what
is your credit score probably pretty
good you don't spend a lot you live
aob style I think it's like 720 or
something that's all right that's good
do you have a little bit of money saved
up you got some cash in the bank are you
a saver yeah that's all I do no stupid
purchases nothing like that n not really
what was the last thing you bought that
was over $500 minus like a like a TV or
something Have you ever bought say the
Austin place but that doesn't that's
yeah that's that's that's a room board I
really only spent money on [__] I need I
bought the lady a nice gift she was her
birthday this past weekend so what'd you
get her necklace okay gold what' that
run you couple Hy what store did you go
to for that
Macy's he left the tag on it yeah oh
yeah me to we were talking about that
yesterday the tag was left on it by
accident so she knows how much it was I
didn't mean to like it was behind the
little cushion thing that the rest of
the necklace was under so then she
opened it and saw it and I pretended
like I didn't well I didn't know it was
there but then I was like oh nice now
she knows how much I what's a couple 200
it was originally like 550 and then it
was on sale so I got it for like three
but the tag on the inside had the
regular
price sweet that's a come up
that's I hit a
lick you deserve it go ahead I work hard
for you nothing to me
did she know that you got it on sale now
she does blew up my [__] spot she
didn't make it this far don't cut this
put it
on man I mean yeah yeah you're trash
[__] baby you don't got to tell me
guys [__] love it dude yeah man'
[__] so much fun I was so excited to
have you I knew it was going to go
exactly like this [__] home run man I
mean dad's a
cop Jersey it's like Liz Clayborn yeah I
mean it's all went to Temple yeah would
she get any free [__] from Liz Clayborn
yeah that's pretty much all the luggage
we have is free stuff from Liz Clayborn
I mean yeah what kind of what kind of
luggage you rolling with now a bass bass
right bass
bass yeah that's what I got okay little
carry on are you TSA pre-check just
clear I should get pre- better yeah
clear's good sometimes I don't have it
though it drives me crazy you have your
passport right yeah okay
yeah I mean the kidss [__] Jersey
trash through baby Matt always says I
live my life as a Bruce Springsteen you
yeah I mean you're not that far off I
live down actually I'm not going to
say
yeah Sean Gardini everybody yeah thank
you gentlemen buddy [__] love it it's
been a pleasure anything you want to
folks out there to know uh just the
podcast uh my podcast the super ultimate
Audio Visual experience with my best
friend big Chrissy I forgot about that I
apologize no that's okay support us on
patreon we need it I'm moving to Austin
I'm bringing him with me are you really
you're taking a friend to Austin yeah
big CH it's like Puerto Rico all over
again everything's bigger down there man
let's go you're taking this squad he's
carrying me on his back we're going down
there I love it kby what do you got for
him uh we're all over the road uh at a
third show in Toronto fourth show in
Chicago get tickets for them they're
going to get scooped up everything else
is selling out so [__] act now before
supplies are gone second show at the
Filmore in Philly is on its way to
selling out get those [__] tickets we
love you gang we'll see you out there
shout out to buzzies sh out to buzzies
can I plug one show away Sunshine Comedy
Fest in Tampa St Pete they got me coming
down there get your tickets it's in
January if you use my name as a promo
code you'll get a discount and then I
get more money there you go g the last
show I'm running at the stand before I
move to Austin is the first Wednesday in
November come to that I'll post about it
please thank you there you go Sean
Gardini everybody nice big round of
applause for the kid [__] love him
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week peace thanks boys